llegamos aquí
[Música]
muchas gracias buenos días bueno he de
confesar que dar una charla sin conocer
el perfil del auditorio es siempre un
poco complicado así que para relajarnos
vamos a hacer un ejercicio a la cuenta
de 321 todos vamos a mirar la pared de
izquierda 3 2 1
a la cuenta de 321 me miran gracias ya
les conozco el perfil
bien todos nacemos con circunstancias en
un entorno de circunstancias que no
elegimos y que sin embargo modifican y
predominan nuestro existir pero
precisamente el reto está
en sobrevolar las en correr nuestros
límites quienes poseemos una
discapacidad diariamente tenemos que
luchar contra dos límites los primeros
llamados sociales que son los prejuicios
y los segundos los físicos que son las
barreras arquitectónicas yo ambos los
eventos y seguramente ustedes también
porque los eventos forman parte de
nuestra vida quién de ustedes nos
festejo un cumpleaños ya que ustedes no
asistió una boda quien no aprendió algo
importante en un congreso y él no compro
algo bonito una tarde de domingo en una
feria o una expo más lamentablemente los
eventos no son accesibles como tampoco
lo son las ciudades anfitrionas que lo
celebran
he visto eventos donde el lugar para
aparcar el coche de una persona con
discapacidad motriz quedaba a 300 metros
del acceso principal
y como hago si no camino y como era una
persona no vidente que recibe una
invitación que no está punteada el
lenguaje braille y cómo orar mejor una
persona sordomuda que va a una
convención y el vídeo no está
subtitulado
sí sí y dado que no hay más que el grado
de facilidad con el cual yo uso accedo
disfruto de un producto o de un servicio
que pasa en latinoamérica no hay reglas
cuando una ciudad de amigable cuando un
recinto es accesible el líder españa
que en 1900 2008 si no me equivoco
declaró accesible al museo guggenheim de
bilbao aquí todavía no hay reglas y
entonces yo me pregunto muchas veces
cómo enfrentar a la gente entre comillas
normal la ciudad la verá como yo la veo
porque cada vez que salgo a la calle y
una construcción no se abre
generosamente hacen mis dos cosas
primero es como si alguien me pusiera
una mano en el pecho y me dijera usted
aquí no entra usted aquí no pasa
sobrando aún más mi diversidad pero
aunque los edificios sean amigables no
dejan de ser fríos trozos de vidrio
niño cemento cal
esos edificios no serían nada aunque
fueran accesibles si además no está la
comunidad esa comunidad en la que
también hay personas completamente sanas
libres de discapacidad pero que tarde o
temprano por el solo hecho de llegar a
viejecitos van a necesitar de la
eliminación total de las barreras
arquitectónicas entonces yo le voy a
pedir a esa comunidad que nos dé a
quienes padecemos una discapacidad una
mirada cálida atenta amorosa tan
distinta tan distante a la mirada que a
veces te brindan en la calle cuando se
voltean para mirarte que uno tiene ganas
de decir por qué me miras por qué me
miras si no es tan grave ser distinto
ahora si lo que es grave es no tener
libertad
pico della mirandola en su tratado sobre
la dignidad humana decía en definitiva
el hombre solo tiene una capacidad que
es la de elegir cómo vive y a mí me
encantaría vivir en una ciudad donde la
diferencia entre calle y acera sea
salvada por una rampa con escaleras
eléctricas que anden con ascensores tan
anchos que entren más de dos sillas de
ruedas porque solo así cuando esa ciudad
exista yo a mi discapacidad le voy a
poder quitar aquí muchas gracias
buenos días
bien aquí
es el tiempo
[Música]